so the trailer ends with the line I'm
not who you think I am well I already
think you're awesome so I do hope you're
that the Captain Marvel trailer yet I
feel like I've been hearing it's gonna
drop any day now for like a month so I'm
really glad that this is finally out
that's a relief to me so I've now
watched it a couple times how I get I
like it a lot I like the visualization
of it looks good
and I like the little snippets that we
get to me potentially paint a picture of
what I'm kind of hoping for first off
right off the bat we cue into that it's
the 90s because oh the blockbuster part
of me really wants a few interior shots
of there because um some of my friends
on the fire and water network they were
like oh how great would it be if it was
like the old Marvel like back when
Marvel stuff sucked like the made-for-tv
Captain America things what if they were
advertised in there I want them to
actually go step further I want them to
have advertisements for knockoff stuff
like how awesome would it be to like I'm
a standee of Jeffrey Koons as dr.
Mordred in there oh that would be a oh
that would make my day but short of that
that's a cool visual shorthand without
having to have a title card coming up
going welcome to the 90s or some
nonsense like that so that was cool I
like the impression that we get in terms
of how it looks like they're going to
fill in her backstory and again this is
just an impression you know it is
distinctly possible for trailers to be
structured in a completely different way
than the film is and to you know point
you in directions that is not where the
phone goes but given how much Marvel
really kind of and Kevin Feige
specifically really kind of put a lot of
emphasis that Doctor Strange was gonna
be their last origin movie I get the
feeling that what we get a sense me
from here is is that she's gonna show up
basically already as a space warrior
like this is who she is now and there
seems to have been some sort of messing
with her head maybe it's you know
conditioning maybe it's you know just
she's been out there so long and been
through so much that her life on earth
feels like a you know something that's
like a dream maybe it's a combination
who knows but I suspect it's gonna be
not dissimilar to someone like Batman 89
where she's just gonna be there doing
her thing and we'll get glimpses back
and flashes back to fill in some of the
stuff which will allow them to get that
information in there without having to
actually build the narrative of the of
this film around explaining her origin
in a traditional origin story you know
covering how she first ends up hooking
up with you know a space army and how
you know how she got there how she
trained that did it I bet we at best or
at most gloss over all that that's gonna
be the little snippets little snippets
we get the other thing that I kind of
zoomed in on is it happened a couple
times were flashes of something
happening to her as a young woman as an
adult on earth and then now and really
like linking up the images so like they
had her falling you know it's sort of
hitting the dirt and there was one of
her just kind of standing up and the
framing of it was such that I'm like
that feels like that needed to have been
shot with the intention of doing that
way so I do think that was actually
indicative of how they're gonna like
have flashes up her past come to her in
terms of something happening to her now
and clicking a memory of something you
know something that happened to her
before when she was on earth originally
now I could still be wrong but the fact
that I haven't more than once in the how
well those things linked up for my money
either that was shot specifically for
the trailer and it's so quick it's not a
highlight moment that I don't think it's
like that you know that hero shot from
the first Avengers infinity ward
you know that big heroes out with ever
warm running including the Hulk that
just flat out is in the movie I don't
think it's like that cuz there's not a
lot of emphasis on these moments so I do
suspect that it is actually reflective
of what we'll see in the film I could
still be wrong about that but that's my
presumption if it is I think it's cool
and the sense that we get of her is
pretty minimal right now we see a little
bit of her powers we get a little bit of
sort of the stoicism trying to find
herself thing which is probably a solid
place to start at it's they could go a
lot of directions in terms of how
they're gonna do Carol you know Captain
Marvel because her history and her
backstory there's a lot to it and she's
had a lot of different identities and a
lot of different skill sets on a lot of
different elements to her character over
the years so there's a lot for them to
pick and choose from which is what I
expect it's what the Marvel movies tend
to do they don't zoom in specifically on
one specific era one specific
incarnation of any of these characters
they tend to pick and choose various
elements that have worked over the years
and bring them all together to sort of
create basically just just the
combination of the best things ideally
so I suspect that's what they're going
for here as well we get a few little
flashes of Jude Law we get to see
Coulson which is nice we see a pager
cool and Nick Fury with two eyes and
hair and Samuel Jackson is just the
coolest kind of planet he's always gonna
be the coolest guy on the planet so
again having him do the narration on
this you know for this trailer and just
all that yeah yeah it works
and and it's I'm not gonna go so far as
the same makes me pumped because I as I
do like a lot of what I know about
Captain Marvel I actually don't I don't
have a lot of direct experience with
Carol Danvers so I don't have the direct
emotional connection with her enough for
this first teeler teaser to really just
whoa
which for a teaser to do that with me I
need kind of a pre-existing investment
into whatever is doing so like first
teaser for
did that first teaser for last Jedi and
force awakens did that first teaser for
spider-man homecoming did that cuz you
know these were characters and things
that I already knew that I love where is
this I'm like that looks like something
I could love and I hope I do I'm really
hopeful for this if for no other reason
then if it's really good I'm hoping that
we'll get to eventually spin-off Kamala
Khan and get MS Marvel out of this
because she'll have her idol to look up
to back in the world so that would be
nice just saying but in any case I like
what I see I really have no distinct
criticisms of what I see I mean the the
flash of the scrolls we hit is real
brief so we're not really getting a
sense of how they're gonna look in terms
of the shifting or whatever cuz
shape-shifting is one of those things
that and we probably won't see it if it
shows up in the trails at all it's not
gonna show up until late in the game
because that's one of those kinds of
special effects that unless you nail it
looks real bad so that's probably why we
haven't seen it and won't for a while
but I mean look not only does she punch
an old woman in the face she punches a
smiley old woman in the face and I'm
sure the reason is because those that
woman's really a scroll but I mean
that's I can't help but laugh at that
and it's just the whole thing just gives
me hope I you know I'm not like this
will be great cuz I don't know enough
yet but what I see here I see a lot of
promise in this I see a lot of things in
terms of what it's hinting to me towards
the approach and the way this is gonna
be told that I think will work assuming
it is what I think it is again first
teaser trailer it could be completely
misrepresentative although Marvel
doesn't usually go too bad on that I
mean they'll do stuff to keep surprises
like do you know the infinity war thing
where they'll hide certain elements like
how every shot of the gauntlet and the
trailers for infinity war only had two
stones even in shots that in the movie
had more than that so that it wouldn't
give too much away or that hero shot
that didn't happen in the movie so you
know that Marvel
we'll do that in terms of you know just
trying to keep people from guessing too
much but they don't do a ton of
deliberately misleading or
misrepresenting the final product so
what I see points to something that I
could potentially enjoy very very much
and the other thing that's actually kind
of nice I can I was like oh we finally
have a trailer I actually like that the
the marketing cycle and he seems to have
shrunk back down to about the six-month
range again which is nice because we had
a couple of years they're basically
kicked off by the force awakens where
the marketing cycle on these things was
a year and I'm really glad that's not
the case anymore I might have to do a
separate video on that about how
relieved I am that that cycles short and
again because I don't know if people
realize how much that damaged some films
and I mean that legitimately yeah I need
to talk about that not sure what I'll
get to it but I will eventually I'm sure
so in any case Captain Marvel trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it today is Wednesday it was gonna
be Doctor Who but I mean I kind of
needed to get this out Doctor Who
tomorrow so whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do because there's
buttons and there's links including to a
patreon so check those out if you feel
like it but remember folks you or the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]